we do it after class it's too close to
class okayy folks uh an announcement
before we start uh Jennifer is part of a
group called The valuation Service Group
that's an undergraduate group that helps
businesses that want their businesses
valued so you can get a chance to
actually try this out in the real world
and real many of them are smaller
businesses that can't pay an appraiser
so they're actually looking to you for a
number so I'm going to let to describe
what the group does how it's structured
and if you're interested you can contact
her and I will send the information
about both the group and how to reach
out to our after class Jennifer use use
that
mic hello okay hello um I'll just take
everyone just for a few minutes and just
going to quickly talk about NYU
valuation Service Group so right now
over these two weeks we are conducting
um EO and also General member
recruitment for this club so NYU
valuation service group is a pro bono uh
NYU student um organization that offers
financing or strategic business decision
a consulting or even just advis for
potential m&a um solutions for small
businesses not only in New York City but
also across the entire United States
region um so if anyone here are
interested in either a leadership
experience or you want to practice your
valuation technicals we conduct DCFS and
also sometimes lbos as well um so not
really about pricing but mainly for
intrinsic valuations or you want to just
talk to clients talk to CEOs and
founders of startup so if you're
interested in VC or creating your own
startup in the future this will be a
great
opportunities um yeah so uh the I'll
send you the application link if you
talk to me later after the class or you
can find it in professor's email later
so we are uh open for both under under
classman upper classman um either if you
have ution experiences or not we are all
welcome open level or um so also it's
either uh eboard or general member so
feel free to learn more as a member
before you appli to eboard but all
welcome thank you so much thank you
J the lbo I would take out don't don't
don't do any lbo stuff you know you
don't want to get somebody bankrupt by
letting them borrow too much money
Bankers can get away with it because
it's other people's money but these
people might actually know where you
live or at least where you go to school
and that's a dangerous place to be um
um usual two questions
with the reframing so the first question
is how many of you have not picked a
company to Value yet subtle change from
last week how many of you not picked a
company you do know that I know you're
lying right because I can see the master
list and it's not all filled up so
either you picked a company and not put
into the master list or you've not
picked a company I'm not going to put
you on the spot God's sakes what are you
waiting for pick a company start the
process soon better to pick a company
and change your mind later than not to
pick a company at all second I did get a
couple of emails from people who don't
have a group yet so the best way to
actually create a group is actually ask
people they're not in a group and if
enough of them put up their hands right
now you can create your own group after
class right how many of you are not in a
group
yet really nobody so who's this emailing
me saying I'm not in a group right so if
you're not in a
group you're not in this classroom right
okay so everybody's in a group at least
in theory most of you pick companies I'm
going to keep my delusions going so I'm
going to act like that is true and keep
moving because even though I know know
it's
not so today we're going to talk about
more about Equity risk Prem if you
remember last Wednesday we talked about
how to estimate a historical Prem by
looking at the past why it's such a bad
estimate for the future right it's noisy
it's backward
looking and then we talked about
estimating risk prams in other countries
I hope you had a chance she out a fire
alarm okay let's hope that was just a
onetime fire alarm I think you're okay
ignoring it if it starts blaring I have
to get you out of here now but today
we're going to talk about a better way
of estimating Equity RIS a forward
looking estimate so today's start of the
class test is going to be structured
around what exactly that estimate is and
what we're going to try to
do is every is everybody comfortable
with how to compute a yield to maturity
on a
bond okay tell me how you compute the
yield to maturity on a bond so you
have Okay so let's pause right there
when you buy a bond it comes with a
maturity and a face value right what
else does it come
with coupon do you get something every
so you get a coupon a face value in
maturity and then you buy the bond at a
price so what's the yield to maturity so
you got the price you got the coupons
the face
value you try different discount rates
to find the internal rate of return that
discount rate that makes the present
value the coupons and the face value
equal equal to the price of the bond we
do this in fixed income all the time
it's a forward-looking number it changes
all the
time so my question is why can't we do
this with equities it's a little Messier
right instead of buying the the bond
what are you doing you're buying stocks
today so you go buy the S&P 500 do I
know how much you paid for it yeah it
changes every moment of every day but
you buy this do you expect to get cash
flows but not coupons right what do you
get instead
well you don't even get residual claim
because you don't control the companies
you get dividends and maybe
BuyBacks and I can't tell you what they
were what they will be in the future but
I can tell you what they were last year
so I know what you paid for stocks I
know what the cash flows were in the
last 12 months can I forecast what those
cash flows will be in the future yeah I
can try right this is the most it's the
S&P 5 the most tracked index in the
world there are people estimating growth
in earnings and cash flows
and I project out the cash flows and
unlike a bond which comes with the
finite maturity dat stocks go on and on
and on forever and I can't estimate cash
flows forever but here's the Escape
escape hatch these are the 500 largest
market cap
companies in the economy they can't grow
faster than the economy for very long so
the end of year five assume that the
cash flows and earnings will start to
grow at the same rate as the economy
and you're going to see me do this over
and over in valuation I'm going to
assume the risk free rate as the proxy
for that long-term growth rate so I'm
almost there I've got your expected cash
flows and beyond your five they will
grow forever at the risk-free rate and
ask the same question I asked for the
bond what discount rate will make the
present value of the expected cash flows
equal to the level of the
index same kind of problem it's a little
Messier because you can't just do yield
to maturity kind of calculations you
have to try so trial and error but in
Excel you can use the solver function or
the gold seek function if you want to
save yourself time but eventually you'll
end up with a discount rate what does it
tell you it tells you based on what you
paid for stocks what you can expect to
earn as a return on stocks I'm almost
there if I subtract other risk free rate
from that I have an equity risk premium
for
stocks I'm going to show you what it
looks like at the start of 2025 and what
its history looks like but before I do
that I want to ask a few word of
questions because if you take this as a
forward-looking number coming from what
you pay here's my first question let's
say that stocks go up by
20% okay the index level is up by
20% so go back to the calculation before
if your index level goes up by 20% what
should happen to your Equity risk
premium should it go up should it go
down should it be unchanged or is there
more information you need to answer that
question you see my question basically
let's go back to the fixed income
example bond price and interest rate
there if the bond price goes up what
happens to interest rates or the yield
to maturity it goes down prices and
interest rates move in opposite
directions is that going to be true
stocks as well for the most part and
I'll tell you why it's not the same with
the bond the coupon is always fixed so
when prices go up the interest rate has
to drop here the price of stock goes up
I didn't tell you what happens to
earnings what if earnings and cash flows
also go up by
20% if the level of the index goes up by
20% and the earnings also go up by 20%
your Equity risk premium is going to
remain the same what drives Equity risk
PR not where the stocks go up but how
much they go up relative to earnings if
they go up a lot more than earnings are
going up your Equity risk premum is
going to decrease if they go up by less
than earnings are going the equity risk
pre premium could actually go up so it's
easy to make mistakes with Equity risk
PR because you think of them like bonds
but stocks are more Dynamic the cash
flows can change the growth rate can
change and you're trying to get a sense
of what the equity risk PR is doing
right another question now we go through
crisis every three or four years there's
a crisis three four years ago it was Co
and a pandemic now again forget the math
you price stocks a crisis hit usually
when a crisis hit what happens stock
prices they go
down so what should happen to equity
risk
premiums they go up during crisis which
is exactly what you'd expect so I'm
going to track you through what the
equity risk bream did day by day from
February 14th of 2020 which was the day
that we heard that the Italians were
having a problem with covid in Italy so
no longer a Chinese problem on cruise
ships it was all over the world we all
walk up to the reality that this was a
global pandemic from February 14th of
2020 to March 23rd one of the worst six
week periods for us equities in a long
long time we'll talk about what the
equity risk PR did during that period
and how to compute it so that's an
implied premium we laid the foundations
but before I go there let me go back to
where I left you with the lection notes
we're talking about estimating an equity
risk premium for a company Siara remind
me again so if I have a company and I
want to estimate an equity RIS of the
company what do I need to to First find
out where it operates right so I can
tell you where it's incorporate so if
you have Saudi company that operates
only in Saudi Arabia my life is easy but
if it's a Saudi company that operates in
Saudi Arabia but also in Egypt and Libya
I've got my task laid out for me I've
got some risky countries in here
and then in the approaches we used at
least through last class what did I do I
took a weighted average of the equity
risk PR three countries are in with the
weights based on
revenues and I told you at that time you
know I'm being I'm using revenues
because I'm desperate it's the only
number I can find broken down by country
and it's the only number that's always
going to be positive you see why that's
a factor right if I wait based on ebbit
or ebbit the problem I'm going to have
is some countries can have negative
operating income and I can't wait based
on negative numbers so it's convenient
but can it get me into trouble
absolutely by focusing just on revenues
I might be missing big parts of country
risk I'll give you an example EMB Brier
Brazilian Aerospace company gets about
97% of its revenues outside Brazil and
primarily in North America and Western
Europe so if I look at just revenues
embri looks really safe it's like a US
company it's like Boeing but all of its
fact trees are in Brazil if Brazil Goes
to Hell in a hand basket amri is going
with
it I'm me ignoring where you make stuff
the production part of it and second the
question is what do I do with that
country risk premium should I scale it
if you're a high beta company is beta
even the right measure of risk if I'm
talking about country RIS so I want to
take those two questions first today
let's start with with with the you know
with what to wait operations by if
you're a consumer product company
revenues work fine you're Coca-Cola
because you know most of your money you
make from pricing up you know what cost
you three cents to make for for $3 in
selling it but I'll get tell you you
know give you an example of a company
where where where you sell your stuff is
completely irrelevant if you're an oil
company what keeps you up at night not
where you're going to sell the oil but
where you get the oil right if you're
getting a lot of oil from
Nigeria and kazakistan
and brunai you got to think about what
the country risk is in those countries
and that's all you care about so a few
years ago I valued Royal
Dutch Royal Dutch oldtime Oil Company
integrated because it does everything in
the oil
space and to get an equity risk Fram
here's what I did I looked at where they
got their oil and gas and most oil
companies if you look through the
footnotes there will be a table and
Royal Dutch had this table of where they
got scary thing about oil is it's put
the riskiest parts of the world or maybe
the converse is true you know once you
get oil it become risky but whatever the
connection is you take the parts of the
world that Royal Dutch has oil and gas
production you take a weighted average
that 11% in Iraq the 10% Russia all play
out to give them an equity risk premium
of 8.26% that was actually higher than
what I was using an as an equity risk PR
for many Emerging Market companies if
you're an oil company I don't care where
you're Incorporated and traded you're
going to be a risky company because of
where you get your oil right and you
could already see that if you're valuing
an oil company that is primarily us and
Canadian based as opposed an oil company
that gets half its oil in Venezuela or
in Russia you're going to have a much
higher Equity risk PR for the latter
than for the
former so you can use revenues you can
use production can you use
both valuation you can do what whatever
you want right you say how do I decide
how much to use a both well one of the
things to look at is how much in this
business do I care about production I'll
give you an example if you're
infosis Outsourcing company your
software people your your your employees
might all be or primarily be in India
your revenues might come from outside
the US but your production is pretty
mobile right so if something bad happens
you can take those people move them to a
different part of the world and try to
insulate yourself
but if you're of motors and your
your physical plant on the ground it's
going to be much more difficult for you
to do it so one of the things are going
to factor in how much you weight
production is hey how easy is it for me
to move production the easier it is to
move production the more you're going to
focus on revenues the less
so the more you care about you know
where your production is so that's a
factor that's going to play out and if
you want to use both just make sure the
weights add up to 100% that's your Only
Rule you can bring both in there's no
one rule that's going to work for every
company so for your company ask yourself
where is the risk coming from and use it
to come up with an equity risk premum
that reflects it any questions yeah
Financial servic It's Tricky right so
yeah that's a good point right so again
the test I run is actually intutive test
if I were the CEO of that bank what's
keeping me awake at night right where
your loans are right so it's not who who
the regulator is or where my
incorporation is it's where my loans are
so absolutely it's what you're going to
factor in any other questions about the
waiting
yes Sophia is bringing in a a wild card
in here we talk about Supply chains
right what did we learn during Co if
your supply chain runs through the
riskiest parts of the
world God help you you might not make it
so Supply chains matter as well so one
of the ways to think about this is if
you have a supply chain that has some
weak look at the weakest link in your
supply chain because that piece breaks
the whole supply chain breaks you want
to factor that this is actually not just
a valuation tool it's a business
management tool right when you decide
how to build your supply chain I'm going
to give you the consequence if you do
that you're going to have a higher
discount rate because you're going to
say that supply chain is cheaper and say
okay that's fine but but because you
have to run through some of the riskiest
parts of the world to deliver it I'm
going to give you a higher discount rate
so I want you to think about all of
those things when you think about
country risk you might still have to
come up with a pragmatic way of saying
this is I'm I can't spend the rest of my
semester thinking about country risk but
think about the dimensions that affect
what the value of your company
is now the other problem I pointed is is
beta good measure of country risk
remember I said you multiply the equity
Risk by Beta you're making a leap of
faith that beta that was designed to
capture exposure to all of the risk
works with country risk as well but
country risk is kind of unique right
yes remember there are two components of
value there's cash flows and there's a
discount rate what you've described as a
cash flow effect it's a very morbid
payoff but if you're a company that
makes Munitions war is good for you
because it pushes up Revenue growth
might even push up margins push up value
it's not a discount rate effect as much
as a cash flow effect and that's
something I want to think about
sometimes we're thinking about things
that affect cash flows and we try to
bring it into discount rates so discount
rates are blunt instruments you can't
bring in those issues it's a cash flow
effect so let's start talk about what
else might affect country risk it makes
it unique and different from interest
rate risk or macroeconomic risk the
first is that when you have country risk
there are things you might do as a
company that reduce your exposure to
that country risk like what you might be
able to find insurance against certain
types of country risk maybe one of the
risks you worry about is
nationalization you might be able to buy
very expensive insurance but insurance
against but what might tar you as a
highrisk company often is the government
decides you're a company in the National
interest when I value companies where
the government deci said you're in the
National interest it's terrifying
because you know what's coming down the
pike right because that government is
going to bind itself with a company and
everything bad happening to the
government will happen to your company
as
well so one of the ways to think about
this maybe beta is not the right measure
of country is maybe we can come up with
a different measure that Expo that
measure is exposure to just to Country
risk I'll tell you when I concocted this
keyword is concocted not just you know
derived because that's just deep thought
it was on a trip to Brazil 20 years ago
and I was going for a valuation seminar
I was valuing two Brazilian
companies one was EMB company that I
just described and the other company is
a company called membe at that time just
a Brazilian beverage company makes a lot
of beer at that time I was doing what
Bankers did which is treat them both as
Brazilian
companies and was a long flight the
person next to me was oozing into my
seat difficult to fall asleep which is
good because I could work on my slides
for the next day so I'm going through
andev and I have EMB and I'm giving them
both same risk premium and I think
that's not fair andev gets 100% of its
revenues in Brazil and Bria gets 5% or
3% of its revenues in Brazil I'm
treating them both as Brazilian
companies wouldn't it be nice and this
is the thought that goes through on a
flight and 30,000 ft up in the air if I
could come up with a measure of how
exposed each of these companies is to
just brazilan country
risk so I concocted this measure I
called it Lambda why because I realized
that attaching a Greek alphabet to
whatever you do attaches a layer of
sophistication to it and basically I
Lambda is my analog to Beta so Lambda
scaled around one so if your Lambda is
one here is exposed to the average
company in the market Lambda above one
means you're more exposed Lambda below
one means you're less exposed so if I
asked you know given the two companies I
described in Brier and be one is going
to have a really low Lambda and the
other is going to have a really high
Lambda right which one's going to have
the low
Lambda EMB Brier because it gets most of
its revenues outside so I started
thinking about what else would I like to
bring into this
Lambda I actually wrote a piece while I
was on the flight still it's still on my
web page on all the things I would like
to know to measure Lambda I start with
the most simplistic measure of Lambda
which is based on just Revenue exposure
why because you want one item you can
get and I said you tell me what
percentage of your revenues you get from
a country I can convert into a Lambda so
here I've taken two Indian companies
TARTA Motors and TARTA Consulting
Services both part of the same family
group in India they're both Indian
companies both part of the same family
group but here's where they're different
T Motors get gets about 91% of its
revenues in India tataa Consulting
Services gets about 7.6% of its revenues
in India already if ask you for
direction Tata consulting services will
have a lower Lambda against country risk
than TARTA modus because it gets less of
its revenues but I want to convert into
a number that scaled around one so I
looked up a third number I looked to see
what a typical Indian company gets as
revenues in India and the typical Indian
company when I did this analysis gets
about 80% its revenues in India I'm home
here's what I did as the final step I
took for T Motors the 91% they get in
India divided by the average of 80% you
have a number that looks just like a
beta right 1.14 Lambda I'm going to take
the Indian Country risk premium and
multiply by
1.14 in contrast if you take Tata
consulting services take the a 7.6 and
divide by 80 the Lambda you get is 0.009
effectively it means when I compute the
cost effect with the expected return
but for Tata consulting services I'm
going to have far less exposure to
Country risk
yeah it'll still be lower but it might
not be as low so question was you know I
said that EMB Brier just looking at
revenues I'm going to get and that's
still going to apply here right the
Lambda I'm going to get is going to be
really low for embri because three % of
your revenues will give you Lambda of
like
0.005 and I'm still exposed to that
critique of where does the the where
your production facilities and they're
all in Brazil that should come at Lambda
the direction is probably still going to
be the same the Lambda is going to be
lower it's just not going to be as low
as 05 but youve raised a good point why
are you still focused on revenues is
there a better way to do it and there is
one and you can try this up you know how
we get betas we run a regression of
Returns on the stock against Returns on
the market index it measures how
sensitive my stock is to Market
movements that's what beta measures what
am I trying to estimate here I'm trying
to estimate how sensitive my company is
to changes in country risk so hang in
there here's what I did I took Returns
on embri and returns in this case of EMB
brle which is a Brazilian phone company
which gets all its revenues in Brazil I
ran regressions against Returns on
what's called a c bond a c bond is a
dollar denominated Brazilian Bond
and I computed the percentage return
each month think of what drives that
return if Brazil is having a crisis the
price of the bond drops the return goes
up so essentially I have a return every
month that captures changes in country
risk and around the regression the slope
of the line basically is like a beta but
it's measured specifically against
country risk so here's the output when
you run this regression the embri
returns give me a slope of .27 what does
that mean every time the return of the
increases by 1% and is up only 27% drops
by 1% it's down by only 27% it's not
that sensitive to returns of the
bond and do the same regression for emle
the SL the coefficient I get is two for
every 1% movement in Brazilian country
risk EMB is twice as
exposed now I have a measure that
captures not just revenues but
everything that's happening the company
because the market has to react to the
composite effects where your costs are
where your revenues are and your total
profits you could you could but be very
unusual right because basically that
means you're actually working in the
opposite direction as your country I've
never seen it happen because you'd have
to disconnect from your country in a way
that you know it's very difficult for me
to see a negative number but if it is
basically it means that this is not the
country risk freem you should be
worrying about there be might be other
countries you have to bring in but I
would not use said in the cost of equity
calculation because it measures at least
from my perspective nothing of value
yes uh for the for this regression or
for for the previous page You' have to
use all companies because lambdas have
to add up to one across all companies
right so if you do it by sector you'll
get the strange not adding up of numbers
that's why when you do betas what's when
you run regressions what are you
supposed to run the regressions again
against the mark against the market not
against the sector returns exactly the
same reason
okay so here's what I'd like to do I've
laid out all these different approaches
this stage you're saying well these
numbers are all going to give me
different
answers I took embri this was in 2004
and I computed five different expected
returns remember these are going to be
discount rates used to discount cash
flows in 2004 I did everything in US
Dollars see that's a cop
out guiltiest charge you know why it
didn't in US Dollars CU in 2004 the
Brazilian government did not have 10year
Bonds denominated in RI if the Brazilian
government doesn't want to deal in R why
should I deal with r right so basically
I stayed with t Bond so the risk the
what you see is a risk-free rate here
because I'm doing everything in dollars
is the US T bond rate 4% at that
time the beta is the same and we'll talk
about how to get a beta for a Brazilian
company so for the moment take the beta
as a given but I've computed five
different expected returns based on
first what I do what I have as my
country risk premium so in the first
approach I just added the entire country
risk premium for Brazil to my expected
return it's the Brazilian company you
get 7.89% more in the second I took a
weighted average risk premium reflecting
the fact that I get only 3% of my
revenues in Brazil and the rest in the
US so I get a much lower cost of equity
because I'm now bringing in the us
exposure in the third approach I went
back to using the country risk bream but
then I multiplied by the beta I five
different cost of equity but rather than
look at them as five different numbers
notice they cluster around two two
groups of numbers in those expected
returns where I treat EMB as a Brazilian
company and don't factor in where they
get the revenues I get much higher
numbers 16 17 18% in those calculations
where I bring in the fact that they get
a big chunk of their revenues
outside I get an expected return that's
much lower 9
10% what valuing umbr right you could
use the 16 to 177% you get treating it
as a Brazilian company or the N9 or the
10% that you get by treating it as a
Brazilian company with significant
developed Market
revenues which one's going to give you
the higher
value the second one right you have
lower discount
rate but make a confession I think
markets take Emerging Market companies
and use a blood gon on them and
especially during crisis okay so if you
look at what happens when you have
significant developed Market exposure
for an Emerging Market company is if
markets don't discriminate across
companies if Brazil is hit with a crisis
and investors sell off Brazilian stocks
they sell off EMB just like they do Mev
or EMB brle or any other Brazilian
company
so I want you to think like an investor
and say look markets are doing the wrong
thing they're factoring in the risk by
looking at where our company's
Incorporated they should be factoring in
where you get your
revenues if that is your starting point
tell me how you would try to make money
of that mistake because markets are
making a mistake right they're treating
all Brazilian companies is the same even
though Embraer gets as much of its
revenues from the us and Western Europe
as boing us
so what will be the the the outcome you
will get as an investor if you believe
markets are making mistakes what kinds
of companies will look undervalued and
overvalued you
yeah or or less exposure so the embs on
the tcs's and the infosis of the world
if you're looking at India in pretty
much every Emerging Market there's a few
companies are going to be too are going
to be priced too low l so what are you
going to do you're going to buy them and
sopia what has to happen for you to make
money they have to come to their census
right and how do you get them to come to
their
census you sit and you hope you know
what usually makes them come to their
census is you get the reality check what
do we say about these companies they are
in a sense not as exposed to what
happens domestically right so when they
report their earnings in the middle of a
crisis their earnings actually hold up
even as the the countries and because
EMB still got the contracts the
long-term contracts so maybe the first
quarter people don't notice this but
after about the third or fourth quarter
where their earnings still come in at at
good numbers where the rest of the
market is melting down maybe then
there's no guarantee maybe then the
correction will happen I have a list of
Emerging Market companies like embri
that have put together list is dated now
but you could probably create a list
like that take each emerging market take
two or three companies like and which
get the bulk of their revenues from
developed
markets don't do anything crazy just
track those markets until there's a
crisis you what if there's no crisis
it's an Emerging Market of course
there's going to be a crisis it's going
to be political it's going to be
economic crisis everybody's going to
sell everything Run for the exit and you
have a buy order ready to go that's the
time to buy the stock I bought and Brier
when Lula got elected for the first time
in Brazil for those of you not from
Brazil Lula when he got elected was
viewed as a communist that he was going
to nationalize everything Market just
completely
collapsed and I remember embri trading
at an incredibly low price was being
treated like every other Brazilian
company it had all these contracts still
with North America and Western Europe
that were still
there and I wrode basically the market
coming it took a long time about seven
years before I could cash out but it's a
strategy to think about is a strategy
built on the premise that markets
sometimes are lazy and sloppy in the way
they treat Emerging Market companies can
you think of the inverse strategy in a
developed Market what are the companies
you're going to sell short on because
it's not long what are the companies are
going if Market yeah
good so if you have a company with 80%
of your revenue is in Argentina it's a
US company and people are pushing up the
stock because it's a US company says
stop this doesn't make any sense so the
inverse of that strategy is to take
company like Coca-Cola and they get
pushed up and say a lot of Emerging
Market risk here you're ignoring so from
both sides of the mistake you're trying
to exploit the possibility that those
mistakes will get
corrected so look at the different
approaches fundamentally the the the big
difference between the two approaches is
are you going to treat your company's
risk based on where it's Incorporated
are you going to treat your company risk
be based on where it does business I
think the ladder makes sense but the
market might disagree with you for a
long time before it finally fixes that
mistake any questions yes go ahead risk
from
that's
both I think the question is does the
place of in Corporation matter if you're
if let's say you have a company with
100% two companies with 100% of their
revenues in the US let's face it you get
none of your revenues in the Cayman
Islands it's a really really really tiny
market right the only reason you're
there is either for taxes or because you
want to create an opaque structure where
it makes it difficult for somebody to
take you
over I think it's more of a corporate
governance issue than an opacity issue
because when I look at financial
statements from the islands they're just
as complete as the financial statements
in the US because if you're going to
trade in the US which is what a lot of
Cayman Island companies want to do your
disclosure requirements are covered by
where you choose to list your stock you
can try to list in the Cayman Islands I
don't even know whether anybody trades
in the Cayman Islands so in Alibaba was
listed it was a Cayman Island shell
company but the trading was in the
NASDAQ so it's not so much a disclosure
issue as a corporate governance issue
what does that mean if you don't like
the way the companies run tough luck if
you're a Cayman if you're looking at a
Cayman Islands company which could then
affect value because if the company gets
badly managed and badly run there's
nothing you can do to fix
it any other questions on
Country so now let's set up the implied
Equity risk premium piece again the
intuition is very simple it says look
you know don't look at the past don't
tell ask people what they want as an
equity riskman just look at what they
pay because that is a number with the
actual dollars going in and it reflects
what you think about risk and you're
doing what you do with with a bond
you're trying to look at what's being
paid and try to back hard of that number
what kind of expected return you know
the intuition here is if you get scared
stock prices go down you expected return
goes up and I want to build that into
the system so that's the page you saw at
the start of the class basically it's an
expected return the IR
calculation and I do this at the start
of every month and I started doing it at
start of every month at 2 and eight and
I'll talk about you know why I didn't do
it every month before that I used to do
it once a year so start of February and
I'll send you the the most recent
implied Equity risk premium number I do
this start of every month for the S&P
500 so let's look at what the number
look like in January
2020 I came into 2020 saying this is
going to be a good year I little I knew
about what was coming so I took the
level of the index so there's the index
expected cash flows based on what the
cash flows in the most recent 12
months and then I use and this is a
basis for most of my projections I look
at what analysts are projecting
collectively as growth in earnings for
the index because I don't want to be
sitting there estimating earnings growth
for each of the 500 companies and the
start of 2020 the the estimate was
earnings growth of about 4% a year so I
projected out the cash flows for the
future at the end of the fifth year what
happens I assume that cash flows will
continue to grow but at the risk-free
rate then which was
1.92% so I've got my index level I've
got the expected cash flow the next five
years and after year five growth drops
off I'm solving for this R this discount
rate as as you can see it's a little
messier than a t-bond calculation but
you can do trial and error start with
six to go with seven ultimately the
number that made my present value of the
cash flows equal to the level of the
index was 7.12% let me pause right there
what does that tell me I don't care what
you hoped you would make what you prayed
you would make what you thought you
would make at the start of 2020 if you
bought stocks at the start of 2020 your
expected return based on the cash flows
and what you paid was 7.12% this is not
Theory it's not it's basically an IR
based on what you paid there's no you
know builtin abstraction about theer you
bought you youve essentially price
stocks earn
7.12% as opposed to what you could have
put your money in something risk- free
which then would would have given you
1.92% that
difference is an implied Equity risk PR
why implied because I'm backing it out
of what you
pay would that number change go back to
2020 Right started 2020 you're feeling
pretty good 5.2% premium and you keep
feeling good until February 14th and
then all hell breaks
loose you got a pandemic the global
economy shuts down this is the implied
Equity risk premium by day through 20 I
used to torture myself every morning I
had nothing better to do I was stuck at
home say what's the AC scam right now he
and I did it by day so there's the graph
so that's February
14th and then you see the equity risk
premium clim think of why right step
back from the numbers what's happening
the world is shutting down around you
you've been asked to go home you're
saying we're not sure whether you'll
have your job when you come back or
whether there'll be school when you come
back we're
terrified it's amazing how in hindsight
we put that all away you see you always
knew this was going to be okay did you
there are days in March I don't know
where this is going to end people were
terrified and it manifested itself that
by the time you get to March 20th in 6
weeks this is the S&P 500 the implied
Equity risk premium Rose almost to
8% this is the essence of a crisis the
price of RIS just dramatically explodes
in a short period because the earnings
and the cash flows can't be changing
that dramatically over that period what
was different about 2020 was how quickly
the market came back from the crisis in
2008 when this happened exactly the same
phenomenon between September and
December of 2008 it took five years for
the market to get back to precrisis
levels in 2020 by September
Market was back
again the market was far more optimistic
than experts were that a vaccine would
be discovered and that the economy would
be okay and expert think Market's crazy
in hindsight though turn out the market
was right and the economists were wrong
this is the advantage of implied
premiums is you can track especially
during and I do this in every crisis I
Go Back to Basics because it keeps me
safe because you listen to people during
a crisis you will lose your head right
you're going they're going to give you
advice that's either terrible or extreme
essentially this says the world hasn't
ended let's figure out what this means
for Equity risk
premiums so I've done that as I said
start of every month start of 2025 I
estimate the equity risk for the S&P 500
same process index now is at
5,831 or
88163717 flows again based on cash flows
in the most recent 12 months and the
expected growth in the future nice thing
about doing this with the s&p500 is as I
said this the most tracked index in the
world getting these numbers is it takes
me 15 minutes at the start of every
month to do it not just pulling the
numbers from
online at the start of 2025 the expected
return on stocks is 8.91% that's better
than the 7.12% that you had at the start
of 2020
right but what do you comp comparing
this number to a t- bond rate of 4.58%
that difference of 4.33% is the implied
Equity risk premium at the start of
2025 I have the February update I'll
send it to you it means let's see if you
can guess which direction it went what
did the S&P 500 do between January 1st
of 2025 and February 1st of
2025 I know you haven't been
yeah go there other direction it went up
a little bit good good good good catch
yeah it it did go up a little bit it
went up to just above 6,000 from 5,000
so if I hold everything else constant
the index goes
up the expected return is going to go
down
right the t- bond rate went up a little
bit from
4.58% already you can see what's going
to happen to the equity risk PR right
stocks go up the t- bond rate goes up a
little bit the equity risk premium went
from 4.33 % to 4.27% you saying that's
not much of a move unless you're in a
crisis that's a kind of move you'll get
on a month-to-month
basis you know where I use this number
every company I valued in January of
2025 the equity risk premium I used for
the US and mature market operations was
4.33% this a couple of days ago yet La
in fact yesterday I was valuing tatan
cement which is a Greek cement company
and enka which is a Turkish construction
company and we're now in February so
guess what I was using as My Equity risk
premium for the US and meture markets
I'd move to 4.27% because that's a
premium what will it be in March I have
no
idea it's forward looking it's Dynamic
and it animates everything I do in
valuation that month as my base from
which I build off all my other Equity
risk
brings any questions about the mechanics
of what we doing here because there's
it's it's not complicated but it's messy
right it's the same internal rate of
return calculation but it's messy
because you you have to estimate the EXP
see and every time I do this I get
people saying what have you got the
growth rate wrong I could have the
analyst estimates could be wrong in fact
they are wrong but as long as they're
not biased I'm okay right so you know
how I check to see if they're you know
what I mean by bias if they're
consistently too high I have a problem
if they're consistently too low I have a
problem how do I check for bias in
analyst
estimates it just gave you the
definition of bias you're wrong in the
same
direction I I just I don't need any
basically I have 20 years of forecast
from analyst I have 20 years of actual
earnings and I look to see year toe
whether analysts were above or below the
actual they're never exactly on the
number they're they're going to be wrong
and in the 20 years I think in 11 years
they undershot growth they
underestimated growth in 9 years they
overestimated growth it's a pretty close
to what you'd expect so I'm okay using
the estimates even though they're
wrong but if they were bias then I might
have looked for a different
Source right essentially I'm using
forecast to get what I think the the
equity risk premium is
today now one are the big question and
it's a question that I think you will be
faced now that you're viewed as having
taken evaluation class you basically
know what what to say about the stock
market is is the market in a
bubble why are we asking that question
why is that question so so so common out
there right now why do you think people
are asking the
question but why is so common now
first is you look at multiples like PE
ratio they look really high and the
second is have you come off really two
really good years or really bad years
for the market we've come back to back
25% return years we haven't had backto
back 25% years in like three decades you
have to go back to the
1990s anytime you have an extended uun
in the market the bubblers come out of
their
caves and you know what follows right
stocks are overv valued you got to sell
everything you got to head with us into
the caves we'll stay there till it's
safe again I've seen these bubblers
every year since
2012 if I'd listened to them I'd have
been out of stocks for the last 13
years so I'm going to give you a
different way of framing is the market
too expensive or not we comput an equity
risk premium 4.33% right that's not your
view my view it's what the market is
building
in one way to think about whether
markets are overpriced or underpriced is
ask is that a fair premium is 4.33%
a reasonable premium to earn an equities
so let's try that do you think that's a
reasonable premium yeah so in which case
what do you saying about
markets they're fairly valued right
anybody want to take the view that it
looks too low I mean let's face all
these macro things coming up tariffs
trade Wars kind of scary stuff anybody
want to take the view that maybe the
risk Rim should be higher than
4.33% when you should be able to and if
you say that let's say you think the
equity RIS should be 6% what are you
saying about
stocks forget about the stock getting
more risky that they're overvalued
anytime you tell me the equity risk
premium you need is higher than today's
number you think saying stocks are
overvalued anytime you say that's about
reasonable you're saying they're fairly
valued and anytime you tell me that
number looks too high then there might
be people who saying AI it's going to do
all kinds of magical things maybe it'll
make the world less risky place I don't
think that's true but maybe that's what
story is and maybe that what follows is
I'm going to take a 3% risk
premium so the question is is 4.33% a
high number a low number or a reasonable
number right so what's a what's a good
place to try to address that what have I
done in this graph you
think I've computed the implied Equity
risk premum the start of every year with
no hindsight bias so basically I went
and put myself back in 1960 I said if I
don't know what's
coming what's it and I've computed the
implied equi from the start of every
year going back to 1960 saying how does
that help me first take a look at this
number is it kind of gone up and down
yeah 1970s the number shoots through the
roof what do you think causing Equity
risk premiums to rise so much in the
70s
what politics almost never affects
that's the nice thing about me in a
mature Market you can have presidents
being impeached or getting close to
impeach Market keeps going that's a sign
of that's good actually it's a sign of a
healthy market is when what happens to
the government actually has only a
residual effect so wasn't water
again inflation inflation is deadly for
oil price embargo Etc triggered it high
inflation is tough because when
inflation goes up everything gets scared
here if that starts to ring a bell
that's what happened in 2022 right
inflation went up Equity risk streams
popped
up so inflation draw back in fact in
1978 the Dow was at
750 there were only three numbers in the
Dow think about that right where's the
Dow at right now
30,000 I remember the headline Business
Week ran stocks are dead you know what
you should learn from this when Business
magazines claim that stocks are dead
it's the right time for you to buy
stocks because we bought stocks in
19778 for the next 21 years take a look
at what happened to equity risk brins
remember Equity risk BRS go up stock
prices are collapsing now that they're
coming down one of the great bull
markets of all
time the equity risk kept going down
down down and during the 90s it
basically fell through the floor by the
end of 1999 the implied Equity risk
premium in the US started 2000 was at
2% now let me ask you the question let's
say this was 2000 and I said the T bond
rate is 6 and a half% which is where it
was I'm going to offer you 2% more than
that to invest in stocks what's your
reaction going to be not enough right
but you know what not a single person
was asking that question then CU we
thought the internet had solved all
economic problems forever that we never
have see another recession again we were
wrong in hindsight but people Justified
it that's a bubble when you look at a 2%
said there's no
way so the risk of cutting you know of
course 2008 you see the spike that's a
2008 crisis there's Co so all the crises
are built in there where are we now
4.33% we're asking is that it's clearly
not 1999 it's not a slam dunk
bubble I actually computed the average
premium across this entire ire time
period the implied premium this is not a
historical premium just the implied
premium from 1960 through 2024 is about
4.25% so the sanguin answer is to say
hey over the last 64 years the implied
premum has been roughly four and a
quarter per that's where we are today so
everything's
okay but I'll give you a cautionary note
since
2008 the implied Equity R in the US has
been about 5 to 5.2 2% we're well below
that
now so there is an argument to be made
that stocks are overpriced maybe not
bubble territory that we become a little
too exuberant about about you know
recessions and bad things that can
happen in which case you have a basis
for saying stocks are overvalued I'm not
going to hold them yes
sopia's that's exactly right and and
it's not just that right in this case
it's it's not just what you are used to
it's what how risk averse you are and
that's healthy right so if you're risk
averse and you think this is a richly
priced Market maybe you'll invest less
of your money in equities than you
otherwise would have and that's a good
response to have to equity risk
premiums I describe myself as a
non-market
timer what do I mean by that I don't try
to time markets you know why because I'm
terrible at
them you got to learn in investing what
you can hand what you can do reasonably
and I I I'm ter which is another way of
saying I've tried in the past to
forecast which direction Equity risk
premium is completely
random that's why I stay with today's
implied Equity risk premum I value
companies because they say look you ask
me to Value Coca-Cola I'm going to Value
Coca-Cola for you I'm not going to try
to pass judgment on the S&P 500 while
I'm valuing the
company there a couple of tangents I
want to take here since I've computed
this implied Equity risk premium each
year I was interested in a couple of
questions first was does the implied
Equity risk premium become bigger when
the risk free rate is higher and I'll
give you the intuition for that let's
say you demand a 4% Equity risk premium
and the t- bond rate is 2% right let's
say the t- bond rate goes from 2% to 5%
this is not a Madea this is exactly
what's happened in the last few years
right would you still accept
4% is your Equity risk premium or would
you demand
more that's I mean I I I don't have the
final answer it's it's an empirical
question why does it matter if risk
premiums become larger as risk free
rates get higher then I've got to factor
in where risk-free rates are to decide
whether
4.33% is
enough so to answer the question I
decide to look at the data so in this
graph what you have the blue is the t-b
rate the red is that EXP expected return
on is a risk premium on top you add the
two numbers up that's the expected
return on stocks if you look at the last
know maybe since 2008 the expected
return stocks has been between 8 and a
half and 9% much of the time of course
the bottom was 2020 and 2021 that
expected return drop to about 5 to
6% so one way to think about this again
is to say look you know if the expected
return is way below what it's been
historically you're going to see a
bounce back of effect but as far as the
relationship between what the level of
the risk free rate and Equity risk fre
in the US outside of the 1970s there's
been no link in other words risk bream
doesn't get higher at higher rates and
lower at lower rates 1970s was the
exception that was a period when
inflation pushed up rates and Equity
risk FRS actually went
down some of you are working with
companies and countries with much higher
risk-free rates in the
US and the equity risk RS you see on my
page are dollar Equity risk PRS on a t
bond rate so if your risk free rate is
15% the Turkish company I was valuing I
was valuing in Turkish L the risk free
rate yesterday was
22.5% that was the risk free
rate I'm feeling a little queasy about
taking my US dollar risk premiums and
adding it on top because I think I'm
going to underestimate the risk premium
at that level so we'll talk about how to
adjust risk premiums when your risk-
free rates start to vary but in the us I
think you can get away using implied
premiums even as rates change because
historically there's been no
link so if I ask you to describe what
the equity risk premium
is can you give me a a working
definition what what is it
measuring
yes it's great it's a price of risk in
the equity market right right that's
basically the price of charging what
goes to the price how scared you are
what's happening the all of those feed
it it's a price of risk in the equity
Market is there a price of risk in the
bond
market when you buy a corporate
bond a default spread
right should the two move together when
people get scared in the equity Market
you think they get scared in the bond
market it's the same people usually
right so here's what I did I actually
took the implied Equity RIS premium
that's a red line I also computed the
spread on a baa rated Bond that's an
investment grade Bond every year it's a
it's Market information I put them on
the same
graph most of the time they move
together but there have been times two
times at least in the last 50 years
where the two have moved in opposite
directions and neither has had a good
ending to the story first was in the
1990s there's the equity risk premium
it's imploding down to 2% remember this
is a spread on a baaa rated baaa is a
very safe corporate bond it's an
investment grade Bond and there was a
time in 1999 where you were making more
by buying an investment grade Bond then
you were buying
equities that was a do com boom what
does that mean if you're an investor and
you're looking at both these numbers and
you're deciding where to put your
portfolio Sophia help me out 1999 99 I'm
offering you 2% on equities and I'm
offering you 2.3% on a baa rated Bond it
put all your money in the corporate bond
why because you're getting a better
payoff on risk and that would have been
a good call because the do com boom
bust and you to be no care with your
bonds that's the first dispar the second
was what happened after 911 in the
US where Alan Greenspan said I will not
allow the US economy to go into
recession the hubris of central
bankers and the way he decided to put
this into practice he was try to push
down default spreads in the bond market
by yapping about rates and talking about
risk and it worked default spreads if
you look at what happened posted to
there's the black line dropping off
Equity risk premium stay high so let's
say it's 2 six and I say where should
you put your money should you put it in
bonds where you're making this tiny
spread for for an investment grade Bond
or going to equities your answer would
be the exact opposite of Sophia's answer
in
1999 and of course what you have here
people are not charging enough for
default risk
right you look at every Market crisis in
the US in the last century almost every
one of them was caused by Equity
investors Behaving
Badly except for
2008 2008 was a crisis created by bond
market investors and lenders behaving
badly I mean lots of different reasons
you can give for 2008 but here was the
core reason when you lend money at rates
that are too
low which is what you're doing when your
default spread is too low eventually
it's going to blow up on you because
actual default is doesn't wait in the
corner saying okay if you tell me it's
low we'll stay low 2008 actual defa rose
to the surface and of course the bond
market took the stock market down with
it
but the reason I track these two numbers
is to get a measure of when the next
Divergence is going to happen I haven't
seen it since 2008 most of the years one
goes up the other goes up and you see
the latest variant last year the equity
risk premium went down so did the
default
spread
yeah there any meaning between the size
of the I did the did the ratio I looked
at the ratio typically it's about twice
the baaa default spread that's your
average across time right now it's much
higher than that which means that either
stocks are cheap or bonds are expensive
you take your PE right but the ratio I
think is a number that I track it's not
something that's big enough for me to
trigger a Red Flag Warning that I have
to do you
know excessive things but that ratio
isn't see how did how come people didn't
see this because once you go to work you
work in a echo chamber where you don't
even know the rest of the world exists
you go to work in equities all you take
care about his equities right you go to
work in fixed income all you look at is
fixed income you know how infrequently
the two people talk to each other this
was happening under the surface and
people didn't even notice because each
group was so focused on its own
Market that they missed the fact that
there was this mismatch going
on so this is the equity Market there's
a bond market there another really big
asset class are missing
right s what is
it you're on to something but what do
the mortgage Market derive its value
from what's the asset class it derives
its value from Real Estate biggest one
of the biggest asset classes out there
is there an equivalent price of risk in
the real estate
market anybody worked in real estate y
it's a cap rate real estate people like
to invest their own concoctions a cap
rate is just a an expected return just
like stocks and bonds why don't they
just call it an expected return because
they want to make it look like they're
special a cap rate so when Real Estate
Investors get really happy the cap rate
goes down when they get really scared
the cap rate goes up a cap rate just
allows you to capitalize income so if
you have a million dollars in rental
income the cap rate becomes a number
that you used to convert to a value so
lower cap rates give you a higher value
so it looks very much like an expected
return so I decided to bring that into
the equation as well why leave it
outside know come to the party so now I
have three different prices of risk on
the same
graph red line is the equity risk
premium the black is the risk premium in
the bond market he saying what the heck
is the green line it's a difference
between the cap rate and a risk-free
rate there seems to be something strange
going on at least pre 2000 right
you have a negative risk
premium sounds weird until you remember
what made real estate such an alluring
asset class for many investors when I
did my MBA one of the things we were
told is you should invest in real estate
in addition to financial assets and what
the logic for that
Sophia because it doesn't move when
financial and when that advice came to
me in 1981 it was absolutely true real
estate actually was negatively
correlated with stocks and bonds so when
you add something that's negatively
correlated you're actually reducing risk
in your portfolio so people said you
know what I'm getting a lower return on
real estate than I would have in
something risk-free but by adding it to
my
portfolio I'm making it safer and then
we sold people on the idea that they
should invest in real estate the pr
investing in real estate comes in big
lumps you know what I mean by big lumps
right you got to build buy a building so
starting in the early 80s we decided
that it would be nice if people could
trade on real estate without investing a
million dollars in a house hence was
born mortgage back Securities and we
securitize real estate this is a happy
ending right great story but here's the
problem when you securitize real
estate it stops behaving like real
estate it starts behaving like stocks
and bonds so let take a look at what's
happened since in the last 20
years real estate is stting to look just
like stocks and bonds you know how this
manifests itself you have a bad year for
stocks 2022 stocks are down you look at
your portfolio oh my God let me look at
my bond portfolio also bad and then you
take a look at how much your house is
worth and what are you going to say it's
also
down this is a terrifying
development because in the old days the
flight to safety that you had in crisis
you sold your stocks and bonds and
bought things that were uncorded real
estate was a logical place I've taken
that place of safety
away because it's now starting to look
just like stocks and
bonds securitization has this side
effect that I don't think we talk about
we talk about all the great things about
securitization allows people to trade
you're right but in the process of
securitizing things we're making it
behave more and more like traditional
stocks and bonds and once you do that
you take away the Ure it has as a
separate asset
class so as I said I do implied Equity
risk FRS all the time I've been trying
to sell appraisers analysts and bankers
on the idea that they should stop using
historical risk premiums and use implied
premiums instead so I'm going to give
you the counter I get from some know so
from some investment bankers as to why
they think it's still okay to use
historical RS actually a confence I with
the bank I updated the numbers I came up
with an implied Equity RIS let's say
4.33% what did I say that's what I would
use the bank is say that's okay we use
8.44 per as our Equity risk premium but
it's okay because everybody in our group
uses 8.44
per. you see the logic right everybody
uses the same risk you know implied
Equity risk premium or the same Equity
risk why does it matter whether it's
right or wrong as long as it's all
consistent tell me what's going to
happen in this equity research group the
markets pricing stocks the 4.33% premium
every person in the group has to use an
8.44 per premium play through what do
you think will happen to the cost of
equi go
ahead flip it around you're going to put
up 8.44 per so your discount rate is
going to be too high your values are
going to be too low everything is going
to look expensive to you right because
the price is going to be much much
higher than the value
so when you use a high discount rate
remember you underestimate value and you
buy when something is cheap and here you
made your values all too low nothing is
going to look cheap to you everything
you look at will be a sell and as a
saleside analyst you won't survive for
very long if you put a sell
recommendation in everything you do so
what do you do you start playing games
with the earnings and cash flow you want
to put a buy recommendation I forced you
to use an unrealistically High Cost of
equity what's the only way you
compensate for it use growth rate that's
twice as size as it should be this is
the path to bad valuation because in a
sense to compensate for one mistake you
create another mistake and you're hoping
that they somehow offset each other but
what universe is that going to be true
so don't let investment bankers say it's
okay we all use 5% you still have to ask
a question is 5% reasonable and the only
way to address that question is to
actually compute and implied Equity risk
PR as of that time
and if it's close to 5% you going to say
that's okay but if it's
3% and using 5% you say everything's
going to look overvalued and if it's 7%
like it was in Co and using 5%
everything's going to look cheap to you
this is no way to Value companies so
even if you don't buy into my implied
aquad scream I'll give you the
spreadsheet you can modify it cuz by now
you know the the logic I'm trying to
come up so you don't like the way I get
the growth rate that's fine come up up
with a different way of getting growth
rate but this isn't again I'm not
creating some elaborate theoretical
exercise the pure internal rate of
return calculation and it's an
incredibly useful number to know even if
you decide not to use
it so is everybody clear why you get the
values you get will be too low you use
too higher discard so anytime use an
equity risk higher than the actual
implied premium you're going to push
down the values of everything and if
you're an acity research channel that
will make create cells and you you use
an equity risk Prem that's lower than
the implied Prem you'll get the exact
opposite
happening so let's look at the choices
here you have historical premiums you
got implied Equity risk premiums and you
have different variations of implied
premiums you can use today's implied
premium you can average out the premium
you can do all kinds of need stuff but
ultimately how do we decide which one is
the best estimate what's the end game
here what are we trying to do we're
trying to figure out what stocks will do
in the future what the actual returns
are so if you have a good measure of an
equity risk premium it should at least
be correlated with what stocks actually
deliver agree and the higher the
correlation the better the estimate of
the equity
risk so I actually take six or seven
different measures of the implied
premium and I went through a few of them
here and I look at this correlation so
remember you want High positive numbers
that's a good what's so you I've taken
four different variations current
implied premium
4.33% maybe you like to smooth things
out an average premium Over The Last 5
Years a historical premium or just take
the default spread and multiply by two
it's kind of a very rough estimate based
on
history of the four approaches to
estimating Equity risk prems which is
the worst
one what do we say we wanted the
correlation
High positive number you want to be
forecasting actual returns being higher
take a look at the Historical pre it's
not even a low it's a negative
correlation this is about as perverse
and estimate as you can get so you are
an appraiser using historical risk
breams using a high number when it
should be low and a low number when it
should be
high and among the other three the
current implied premium actually does
the best job in forecasting actual
returns in the next year the next five
years next 10 years my defense for using
the current premium is not based on some
ego it's based on the fact it works
better if I'd find the default spread
based approach work better I'd say
multiply the default spread by two think
of how much easier my life would be at
the start of every month so I will
continue to use a current implied
premium I'll update in February but you
don't have to wait for me to update I
might take it know sometimes it takes me
a couple of days in March to get to it
you can beat me to it you'll have the
the the same spreadsheet I'm going to be
using you'll have in today's email
you'll get as a link update it all you
have to do is update the index update
the T bond rate run the goldseek
function it comes with instructions on
how to run you can update it every day
if you want I hope there's no crisis but
if there is there is an incentive for
you it's a good way to get a sense of
what it is that's
driving now when I did historical
premiums remember I said it's almost
impossible to do this for an Emerging
Market why is that again why is it
difficult to get historical risk
premiums that you can use in a in a
Vietnam or
a there not enough data right but if I
do an implied premium can I do it for
any Market no matter how short its
history what are the things I need I
need the level of the index can get that
in any Market I need cash flows last
year I should be able to get it might be
only dividends in that market I need
expected growth for the next 5 years and
It's tricky in a Vietnamese Market but
if I you know try to know if I was a
pragmatist I could probably come up with
a number but if I can get those numbers
I can solve for an implied Equity risk
premium for a
market let's try this in uh this was in
2007 I wanted to get an implied Equity
risk premium for the sensex the Indian
Equity index so I got the level of the
index
15446 dividends were the only thing
there were no Buybacks in India at that
time so all I had to do was so it
actually made my life easier for the
expected growth I had to cheat because
unlike the S&P 500 where there are
analyst of forecast earnings growth for
the entire index here I had to get
growth rates for individual
companies and for most of them I got a
growth rate only for one year the only
companies where I could get a fiveyear
growth rate were Indian companies with
adrs you know what adrs are the listings
in the US so the companies like INF
fores that at adrs I was able but I kind
of cobbled together the numbers and I
came up with a growth rate of 14%
the risk free rate that I had then for
the Indian rup was 6.76% so I'm going to
set up the process I have the level of
the index I projected cash flows with a
14% growth rate at the end of the fifth
year I assume that cash flow will
continue to grow at a
6.76% rate that's solved for required
rate of return
11.18% you subtract out the risk free
rate then the implied Equity risk PR for
India in 2007 was 4.42%
last week I did this for the sensex
right now anybody who's been tracking
Indian equities what have they been
doing for the last
decade really good things if you're an
investor index is at Sky in fact you
talked about price earnings ratios for
US stocks looking high at
2122 India was the priciest market in
the world at the start of 2025 31 times
earnings all of this if you put the
numbers in then in implied Equity risk
bream the implied Equity risk bream in
India right now is about
3% remember me again what the premium
was for the us at the start of
4.33% now you can do all your India
India story dances you want about the
growth and the amazing thing I've built
that all into the cash flows with the
growth
rate if you're accepting a 3% premium
for a market that still has
substantially more risk than a develop
mature
Market got to be out of your mind right
but I'll cut Indian some slack on
this when I'm an investor and I'm
looking at the US Equity risk premium at
4.33% and the Indian premium is 3% how
does that play out in my portfolio
choices I can choose where to invest my
money right so guess where I invest my
money more in US Stocks very little in
Indian stocks why can't Indian investors
do the same I I want somebody from India
to answer this question why can't Indian
investors pull their money out of Indian
stocks after all they're incredibly
overpriced and move them to the US the
UK Germany
yes there are restrictions you can
invest up to what
$250,000
and basically so you are in a sense and
be glad it's 250,000 because when I was
growing up it was Z dollar you could not
invest outside
India if you Coral people and force them
to invest in a market you don't give
them Escape hatches it's a very
dangerous thing to do you think they got
away with it 40 years ago when India was
a tiny economy in terms of GDP now we
have what the fifth largest economy in
the world China has a variation of the
same problem I'm talking about mainland
China versus Hong Kong is you had to put
Coral you countries are getting
wealthier there's more money to invest
and there's no place to
go so what do you do you pile into
equities even though the pr premium is
too low but even in markets like India
where I give you no Escape pches at some
point in time you're going to say no I'm
not doing this anymore and then what do
you do you take your money out of stocks
you go looking for something else to
invest in in India historically this was
real estate this was
gold basically you have a moving bubble
that with this much money it's got to go
somewhere so what's the effect what
should the Indian government start doing
kind of logically follows
you got to remove these Capital controls
you got to do it gradually you know why
you got to do it gradually right if you
remove them all tomorrow what's going to
happen Indian equities are going to
collapse every Indian company what the
heck happened here because you've given
them this great way of raising Capital
at really low expected returns they're
not going to voluntarily say this is
amazing go ahead and take the but you
got to start doing this India is not a
small economy anymore and if the India
story is even partially true this
problem is only going to get worse
rather than better and the nice thing
about implied premiums is you can
essentially make this statement and
you're not making a statement about
qualitatively I'm not saying this it's
really about this is what the numbers
are giving me as an expected return and
a risk premum so on that note I will
leave you to your thoughts and I will
see you on Wednesday